i have a story
welcome to texas
i have a story
okay
i'm in west texas where this family just
lost their daughter to an opiate
overdose oh my god i'm so sorry it's
okay it's not someone i was close to but
you flew to texas for it uh
yes uh it was a girl i hooked up with a
few times her family thought that we
were more serious than i did i've heard
so much about you i've i've heard
[Music]
abilene just didn't die she was murdered
what and the two of us are going to
venture dead
so as like a personal boundary i don't
avenge deaths but here's what i can do
i'm going to record everything that you
think happened to abilene
and we'll put it on a podcast and we'll
see where it leads what evidence does he
have that it was a murder
nothing
and that's the story
what's this podcast about a new american
reality where people invent these
conspiracies you got deep state pill
pushers cartels the law because the
truth is too hard to accept
my prius exploded oh my god what if
you're driving a real car with gas and
stuff
the problem isn't that these people
aren't smart the problem is that they
are how do you take them coffee
in the mouth
if you want people to open up to you you
gotta act like one of us
who here is a diehard fan of the
university of texas
[Applause]
and who here is a fan of texas tech
what if she was murdered
this just keeps getting bigger and
bigger looks like two pairs of prints
cowboy boots calling out an apb to find
two men wearing cowboy boots
what happened to her why do you care so
much why do you care so little
you're so lucky in you evelyn i really
don't know what you saw i mean art sees
art
texas has a full rudder
you can't solve something like this with
a 45. it's the breakdown of society's
what it is
i think that's very nice you're going to
need a 12-gauge couple of ars no western
automatic and a sidearm for safety
where are you right now uh i'm in an
uber
[Music]
[Music]
you